[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on accueille le premier candidat c'est
parti et qui pourra
bonsoir comment tu t'appelles venturi
jérémy bonjour j'ai rêvé ça va tu es
bien d'où je viens de paris tu es marié
j'irai vie non je célibataire j'ai 30
ans non ah ouais toi me brandt est beau
gosse son écrin j'aime beaucoup
ouais c'est vrai ah oui oui oh là là là
là à l'essai par thibault giresse
il va alors c'est l'histoire d'un gars
il marche tranquille dans la rue et ils
voient un ami d'enfance comme ça il dira
michel comment tu vois ça fait longtemps
et où il y voit comme ça son pote avec
deux grosses valises dans la main tu dis
que tu fais de grosses valises comme ça
michel je peux pas te raconter c'est une
histoire de fous tu vas jamais me croire
edit bon raconte moi il lui dit ok bon
français de valises ou la gare il va il
un île où la valise qu'est-ce qui voit
dedans il voit une grosse me tient un
site et nantes qui le regarde comme ça
le mec qui prend peur il ferme la valise
il dit c'est quoi cette histoire là
illizi bon il ya quoi dans votre valise
il est dit bon d'asie ouvre là et ils
houria quoi dedans un génie comme ça qui
sort qui le regard qui lui dit bonjour m
vous pouvez réaliser en veut qu'elles
sont pas tus je dis c'est quoi cette
histoire de l'histoire ce génie bon pas
de question
c'est un voeu est il en panne et qui dit
ok outils génie je veux un milliard le
génie on regarde le dit très bien m je
vais réaliser votre vie et paf le mec
qui disparaît ok qu'est ce qui se trouve
à côté du gua un billard mais qui
regarde son pote jeudi michel c'est quoi
cette histoire j'ai demandé un milliard
et je me retrouve avec un billard sont
pas tous le regard comme ça il dit je
crois vraiment que j'avais demandé une
grosse mythe
ah les médias un peu dur jérémie berrebi
on va accueillir celui que tu vas
affronter va acquérir le gagnant
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci jérémy et on va accueillir les jo
malone marle away quand même énorme
c'était dans un dans un boys band
je suis fan de laurent baffie de jean
marie bigard non mais chanter ma mère si
tu as n'avoir semaine vous vous êtes mon
idole mais ça n'a rien à voir mais
laurent pas si j'ai une préférence juste
marlon pas du tout il a juste compris
qui donnait losail 1 j'en perdais pas
avec ça il sait que ça s'en va la main
c'est tout et franck gastambide tu veux
bien super ça marrant parce qu'il a
regardé syrie va donc en fait c'est
l'histoire d'un couple de vieux tiendra
bientôt mourir donc le mec il est au
chevet de sa femme dans l'eee et je
chéris pour avant de partir en paix va
dans le grenier j'ai une surprise pour
toi il ya une valise noire qui t'attend
mais qui va dans le grenier shop la
valise noire
il ouvre et il ya 3 e et 150000 euros et
va voir sa femme et lui dit chérie ça
fait 50 ans qu'on est marié jamais tu
m'as parlé de cette valise qu'est ce que
c'est les 3 e dedans et viva écoute les
3e chérie c'est qu'en cinquante ans de
mariage à chaque fois qu'on faisait
l'amour et que je n'avais pas d'orgasme
je m'étais 1,9 de côté et viviez 150000
euros évier 150000 euros
dès que j'avais une douce end of the la
revendaient au marché
[Applaudissements]
pour vous qui a gagné c'est laurent
baffie cétacés corse et franck
gastambide qui vont décider même tout le
monde ayant bonifié alors lot 5 pour moi
c'est évident je dis allemand c'est
marlon marlon ludivine au nom mais
j'aimais chocolatines a eu des beaux
gosses pas donc chocolat tirait il
tirait chocolatines chocolatines donc
gérer une mare a mare de partout marlon
bâle iii de syrie marlon mari j'ai
besoin de me prononcer on le sait tous
des jeunes
ouais c'est vrai que listed à fond ça
ici attention c'est ses rires je crois
qu'on voit la c3
alors alors alors c'est pas évident
celle ci avait fait tous les deux très
bons pendant qu'au sol et je vote pour
l'espoir à des votes pour marlon malone
donc ça nous fait 4-3 pour marlon franck
gastambide c'est vous qui allez décider
mais moi je bats non pas du tout je vais
relancer le jeu et je veux dire jérémy
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai deux seules choses que vous
savez que dans mes émissions je crée des
règles en direct les assauts blanche et
de solutions qui sont pro series soit un
ratio pay soit soit je prends la
décision
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait on
est huit chroniqueur plus franc que ça
fait 9 ayant vieilli
oui mais ça c'est la régie ses huit
tombes avec saragosse tous des erreurs
et y aura toujours des erreurs et ça
fait partie du jeu est à présent je me
pose
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux solutions soit bien soit bref
ça prend la décision
le feu un pousse toi china ça me ferait
de la peine et donc je me dis je vais
donner ma voix aux gagnants ou bien ce
chiffre change les règles
voilà et je décide que la voix de
l'inviter compte 2 oui oui mais alors ça
j'ai fait pas au courant et là ça change
d'appareil à ce qu'ils aient la
possibilité pour marlon jérémy de faire
250 euros chacun on n'est pas au souk
ici on n'est pas gagnant je vais
demander à la rixe oppose
je propose une règle franck raconter une
histoire il prend son poulain moi je
prends la relève et vous mettez pour la
blague de franco les miens
[Applaudissements]
j'avais déjà fait de la télé avant de
s'achever avec thierry ardisson gagner
une fortune mérité le double merci merci
je prends monsieur mais a été le
quadruple n'oublierai pas ces y avoir de
mer donc alors donc en fait
du coup ça fait 6 75 euros chacun si
vous nous rejoignez 250 / kg 50 vous
allez avoir donc chacun notre champion
donc toi tu ton cours pour jon la
charlotte et doit concours pour gérer sa
mère bon ben je déciderai de la
meilleure blague
voilà d'accord comme ça faut rajouter
ses mots comme en nature jusqu'à 22
heures bal avec abyss en tout cas moi je
me suis trompé de 25 ans a tenté on va
laisser à tous raconté les baisers à ses
bas non parce que j'ai toujours voulu
faire ça
[Applaudissements]
gaston petit vase ippon alors ses lapins
dans une forêt qui courent ils courent
ikue puis il tombe sur un sur un renard
qui est en train de se faire un gros
joint debout tu vois et luigi un renard
arrête de fumer ça tu vas t'abimer la
santé vient plutôt courir avec moi dans
la forêt tu as raison marly jeta qui
jette son âge et par courrier avec lui
et puis d'un coup il croise un chevreuil
dans la forêt et le chevreuil est en
train de se faire un gros ce rail de
coke
ah oui et lapins et lui dit chevreuil
arrête de prendre ça tu vas tu abîmé la
santé vient plutôt courir avec nous dans
la forêt ouais c'est vrai tu as raison
tu as qu il met un coup de sabot dans le
sac ok il partant sans courir
et là il tombe sur un sanglier et la
halle sangle il une grosse patate dans
la gueule et tout le monde lui dit mais
pourquoi tu as fait son lapin il sanglé
lui dis parce que ce bâtard de lapin
quand il est sous ecsta il nous fait
chier pourquoi la cour est inclus dans
la soirée
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas eu notre thé bien moi je vote
confronte à une plus propre la bafi
autre poulain c'est donc marlon ou
marlon concours est pour marlon ancien
lequel franck gastambide gastambide vous
avez raconté de votre blague au nom de
jérémy hau ça va jouer maintenant
laurent baffie on écoute ses deux potes
ils sont en vie ce trop il y en a un qui
lie [ __ ] ma vie est foutue
ma vie est foutue je suis grillé par
tous ces morts et son peu de fat en te
prends pas la tête tu es pas le premier
toubib avoir une aventure avec un
patient effet oui mais moi je suis
vétérinaire je te rappelle areva annonce
était ignoble
non laurent wavy franck schott
non c'est la non non thomas mais rapide
efficacement d'en tirer coran jean marie
frin qu'il y avait un truc
d'interprétation et offrez-lui alors
évident
[Rires]
3 s'il ya dehors c'est ça oui non les
sessions et soit la ram à son régime
chronique
le comptable je vote pour laurent baffie
pas fait mon choix apparemment je suis
le seul à voter
il ya 4 3 lors on sait donc toi qui as
gagné
évidemment j'en prenais désolant mais
c'est n'importe quoi attendez pas ce que
l'on me pose une question c'est vrai est
ce que tu as envie de revenir à ce
voyage parce que au risque de tout
perdre
donc je pense revenir tu reviens ouais
la semaine prochaine ouais au réseau ip
a très bien géré leurs avoirs
[Applaudissements]